[Musica]
allora c'è un mantra che
gira per l'europa e non solo per
l'europa
che dice che la grande litigiosità che
sta travagliando il mondo che ci
impedisce di affrontare in modo
intelligente
e collaborativo i nostri problemi è
dovuta al fatto che tutti parlano e
nessuno ascolta e quindi tutti dicono
che ci ascoltasse degli altri
ascoltassero le cose forse sarebbero
molto meglio
io penso che questo sia sbagliato io
penso che questo mantra sia superficiale
fuorviante e anche su poriferi nel senso
che ognuno pensa che siano gli altri che
non ascoltano e quindi
scaricabarile sugli altri in realtà
penso che un modo più serio per
affrontare i problemi attuali e quello
che ha posto questo sociologo tedesco e
si amauri beck che ha detto che tutti i
principali problemi del nostro tempo
nascono dal fatto che noi abbiamo il
corpo nel xxi secolo e la testa in modo
di pensare e le istituzioni che sono
rimaste al xix secolo
allora se voi prendete sul serio
il corpo non so se questo cellulare
attaccato a me o se io sono attaccata al
cellulare una delle due cose il
partendo da questa osservazione
una cosa che ti può venire in mente che
in realtà non è vero che noi non
ascoltiamo ascoltiamo moltissimo
parliamo moltissime ascoltava moltissimo
ma ascoltiamo come se fossi bone
corrermi xix secolo con una mente con
una modalità di ascolto che era andava
bene due secoli fa e che oggi non
funziona più perplessità diventata molto
diversa una città complessa
quindi il st di capire qual è la
differenza tra l'ascolto è già avevi un
secolo e l'ascolto che funzionano il
ventunesimo il sempre uribe che dà anche
un'indicazione sopra come si dovrebbe
ascoltare
quindi se bisogna passare da un
approccio dell'atteggiamento o ha un
atteggiamento e
e quindi io vorrei
fare un esempio perché io fin da piccola
piena che in famiglia
già nella mia famiglia avevo una ridotti
che familiare che mi ha abituato al e e
vi faccio un piccolo esempio che è
legato a due parole una parola
e burro e un'altra e mais
burro la signora entra in un negozio
e chiede un etto di burro tutte le
persone presenti scoppiano a ridere
scoppiano a ridere la guardano e ridono
cosa è successo è successo a difesa
signora si trovava in brasile
e ha chiesto di sas di burro por favor
quello che burro in portoghese vuol dire
asino e quindi la gente la guardava e
rideva per questo questa signora era mia
madre
mais un signore parla con del signore
americane e per fare un loro un
complimento
dice io adoro il mais lesso spalmato di
burro ai wav boiled miles spread sbatter
problema che mais in inglese vuol dire
topi e quindi ha detto adoro i topi
bolliti spalmati di burro
ovviamente le ragioni delle signore era
una lezione
criticata già non sapevano poi dopo
quando hanno capito che mai si diceva
corna in una città mais messi tutti a
ridere di nuovo
io già avevo imparato attraverso questa
aneddotica familiare che non era solo
all'inter linguistica ma anche sulle
cose della vita quotidiana che le stesse
cose hanno significati diversi e che
questi incidenti in realtà sono
utili impari meglio a capire in paris
meglio la lingua attraverso questi
studenti può inoltre dimentichi più e
impari che le stesse cose in contesti
diversi
significati legittimamente diversi che
quindi per capire il senso delle cose
deve collegare queste cose con i
contesti che le varie parti danno per
scontato e quindi questo è il
quindi burro voleva dire asino mais topi
allora qui c'è una tabella che presenta
come un pensiero semplice in un sistema
semplice va bene ascoltare come nel xix
secolo che vuol dire un ascolto
giudicante cioè le persone parlano e io
mentre ascolto penso vero falso chiuso
sbagliato amico nemico allora adesso
intervengo per spiegare che questo è
giusto sull'accordo questo sono
d'accordo su privato sulle eccetera
quindi hai un atteggiamento
continuamente giudicante e una
trasformazione
della diversità e del conflitto in
percentuali in cui i dati quantitativi è
infatti la decisione poi viene presa a
maggioranza quindi che posizioni abbiamo
da cerchi di
sminuire la diversità
riducendola a percentuali top pensano
così top così top così quindi vediamo un
attimo cosa pensano eccetera il lasco
nel sistema complesso questo produce
litigiosità produce conflitto nullo non
riesce a risolvere per trasformare il
conflitto in una risorsa
io devo imparare dal conflitto deve
essere contenta che
emerge un conflitto perché chiedendo
cerca di capire i motivi per cui
quell'altra persona la pensa in modo
diverso acquisisco delle informazioni
che poi sono utili per una progettazione
peraltro insomma è quindi in un sistema
complesso questo vale per la fisica come
per la sociologia
le stesse cose hanno significati
differenti il
controllo non è più un controllo in cui
devo prevedere cosa succede ma io devo
saper trasformare
[Musica]
smentita in un'occasione di
apprendimento
e ed è anche molto divertente se non lo
fa in modo giocoso si capisce cosa come
funziona questa cosa corano e quindi
viviamo ormai non più riverso e non più
in un universo in in un mondo
pluriculturale anche all'interno della
nostra stessa lingua e cultura
ormai la comunicazione fra generazioni
fra maschi e femmine eccetera è
fondamentalmente una comunicazione
interculturale
come quando è che ho capito che questo
imprinting umoristico non era
semplicemente un modo per attenuare la
propria frustrazione quando 1 fallisce
era una cosa molto più seria l'ho capito
quando 16 anni 50 60
sono andata per un anno con la seven
sins una nave che partirà da rotte dal
piena di giovani europei per un anno
negli stati uniti e durante questa reati
uniti con una famiglia americana
nascondere i carnet eccetera
con il successo è successo che ho capito
che la vita era un
continuo incidente perché queste
situazioni di
attese disattese erano quotidiane su
ogni sulle piccole cose sulle grandi
cose e io grazie all'input in familiare
affrontavo tutte queste cose come
veramente occasioni meravigliosi di
apprendimento non solo è l'affrontare
così ma quando militavano parlare
racconta la mia esperienza
lo diceva raccontavano le mie esperienze
scendo io mi sono trovata italiana di
fronte un professore che insegnava quei
pantaloncini corti ero ipnotizzato dalle
sue gambe pieni di peli non riuscivo più
ascoltare tutti che ridevano e io mi
chiedevo ma nella mia cultura che
rapporto hanno i pantaloni lunghi con la
conoscenza con l'autorevolezza quindi io
capivo grazie a questi piazzamenti mi
vedevo dall'esterno me stessa e il mondo
di cui ero parte
quindi questo allora grazie a questo io
ho fatto un anno di di studio poi ho
preso un sabbatico insegnava non esita a
queste cose però l'hanno studiato il
rapporto tra umorismo e conoscenza e ho
scoperto che tutti i più grandi geni
praticamente c'erano già arrivati cioè
ritengono che l'umorismo sia una forma
superiore di intelligenza e di
comprensione più approfondita della
realtà perché una compressione in cui
come minimo deve avere due punti vista
divergenti per capire una cosa e
descriverla e la teoria che sta alla
base di queste
tutte convergenti di queste cose la
teoria della doppia illuminazione che
qui adesso vi vi spiego perché come un
esempio preso da una battuta di mark
twain che dice non è vero
smettere di fumare è difficile io smetto
tutti i giorni allora come funziona la
battuta funzione che c'è una prima frase
non è vero che le di fumare difficile
che una frase che tutti intendono in un
modo secondo il senso comune smettere
definitivamente per una battuta ribalta
completamente questa prima
interpretazione perché vuol dire
continuare a fumare con delle pause
quindi proposto e io invece essendo
stata smentita invece di irrigidirmi
reagire colasio difendendo la mia prima
interpretazione accolgo ridendo la
seconda interpretazione e
immediati rido e capisco la 2p
illuminazione ne parla freud
nell'introduzione al motto di spirito le
sue relazioni con inconscio la dubbi
nomi ai suoi corsi sul fatto che non
sono smettere aveva anche un altro
significato
ma io quando pensavo che l'unico
significato possibile fosse il mio
iniziale ero arrogante c'è un rapporto
tra potere conoscenza di cui l'umorismo
la dinamica dell'umorismo che rende
consapevole e quindi questo è
questa sera per la cosa
allora
questa cosa qui quando insegnavo al
politecnico queste cose
ho incominciato 30 anni fa questa cosa
invece ha bisogno trascinata occuparmi
di progettazione partecipata
qui mi sono occupata all'inizio anni 90
del progetto speciale periferie di
torino nel quale il sì ma gli abitanti e
quartiere in crisi i funzionari del
comune e il professionisti urbanisti
antropologi setore dovevano fare un
piano di riqualificazione restare
risanamento ai quartieri in crisi mi
sono trovata a lavorare con una decine
di persone molto diverse fra di loro
alle quali non è che potevo insegnare
delle cose specifiche all 1 io dovevo
creare un contenitore in cui si
ascoltassero spontaneamente e quella che
ho scoperto che creando questo
contenitore in cui c'è un'attesa
reciproca di ascolto e rivolge di casini
la gente lo fa quindi quello che ho
scoperto che si è veramente molto
importante per la crisi della democrazia
oggi è che il problema della litigiosità
non è principalmente un problema di
carattere individuale è principalmente
un problema di carattere delle
istituzioni
se io cambio il protocollo i regolamenti
i modi normality funzionari delle
istituzioni da gente si comporta in un
modo diverso per ora è difficile quindi
questo è una foto del progetto speciale
periferie
allora le regole diverse che devono male
le istruzioni sono il passaggio da
diritto di parola diritto e
contraddittorio voto ha diritto di
essere ascoltati di tutti
moltiplicazioni diritto e di
moltiplicare le opzioni prima di
decidere diritto di co progettare le gt
della propria cosa
la differenza fra l'ascolto collettivo
ascolto il gruppo d'ascolto politico che
noi attuiamo talmente e quello che
invece dovrebbe saturato può essere
illustrata con questo grafico lui
attualmente facciamo così ci riuniamo
sul tema ognuno può nella propria
posizione quindi hai un arco di
posizioni che si presentano appena e
questa divergenza di ci facciamo un
tavolo e troviamo la soluzione quindi la
diversità innatamente viene vissuta come
qualcosa di fastidioso e difficile e
richiudere invece una istituzione che
funziona sulla base dell'ascolto attivo
in ascolto capace di trasformare la
divergenza il conflitto in risorse
conoscitiva funziona così il tu hai che
all'inizio ognuno pone le proprie
posizioni ma questa apertura invece che
chiusa rimane aperta e le domande sono
domande per capire meglio le ragioni di
ognuno
se vuoi capire quello che un altro sta
dicendo devi assumere che ha ragione
tutti hanno ragione cerchiamo le ragioni
tutti quando io faccio questa operazione
alla fine l'esito è un arco di proposte
tutte legittime di cui abbiamo capito i
motivi abbiamo capito le preoccupazioni
che stanno alla base c'è tra e ognuno si
chiede come facciamo a farci carico di
questo quindi passiamo dall'io al noi
dalla mia proposta contro l'attuale la
nostra come facciamo elaborare una
nostra proposta questo si chiama emerse
emersione dell'intelligenza plurale
dell'intelligenza collettiva questo
punto non hai nessuna soluzione
l'associazione la trovi tutti diventano
esploratore di mondi possibili andiamo
in giro a vedere le situazioni che ci
sono sempre nel mondo perché il nostro
mondo è vario creativo ea a tantissime
proposte
andiamo a vedere la dove hanno già
affrontato queste cose in modo
interessante impariamo tutti insieme per
queste cose quando arriva un'idea
interessante
intorno a quella si può un comitato che
sulla base e tutto questo lavoro fa una
proposta e allora solo adesso
stringiamo dopo aver fatto l'ascolto
dopo aver fatto la moltiplicazione delle
opzioni
a questo punto si può fare la la e
ricorriamo al al voto maggioranza solo
se falliamo nel co progettare
maggioranza è una cosa qui ricordo
quando fallisce fallisce il dialogo la
proposta positiva
quindi abbiamo due diversi frattali che
stanno alla base di due tipi di civiltà
uno basato su o come dicevamo ribeca
d'inizio l'alto basato sul e
il 7 regole ed alta ascoltare che ho
elaborato ormai sono diventate sono
appesa per tutto quella che vi ho appena
detto se vuoi capire quello che sta
dicendo deve assumere che ha ragione
l'ultima che poi riassume tutti anche
che vi ho detto adesso è
se vuoi imparare ad ascoltare deve
dotare una metodologia umoristica
dell'umorismo è un campo di allenamento
per la creatività per la gestione capire
conflitti per un ascolto attivo è certa
però una volta che imparato ascoltare
una buon ascoltatore è fondamentalmente
un umorista
deve delle riunioni fatte su questi
principi sono sempre riunioni che hanno
una struttura circolare non esistono più
le file righe di una volta perché la
gente deve poter parlare a un livello di
parità faccia a faccia mettere in gioco
la propria unicità dalla propria
esperienza quindi questa è una tipica
sembra del xxi secolo
ogni tavolo estremamente differenziato e
finisco con una citazione di di bad
gastein che dice non è vero che
un'eccezione
è una conferma la regola
un'eccezione è una occasione per
esplorare qualcosa di nuovo
il e l'umorismo non è uno stato d'animo
ma è un modo di guardare al mondo quindi
io grazie a questo the top o collegato
la seven seas la nave con cui sono
partito a 16 anni con le mie sette
regole seven server e penso che fra i
due oltre la parola 7 c'è anche una
storia di vita o di apprendimento con la
quale mi piace finire questo top mi
sembra un finale aperto e vi ringrazio
dell'ascolto
grazie
[Musica]